once again I Never Promised You a Rose
Garden bringing the show down to Austin
Texas January 13th and 14th at the
Vulcan and then New York again Levittown
New York at Governors January 20th and
21st come and check out all these shows
more being added all the time stay tuned
get all your Show tickets and all your
show info joeinfo.com also please check
out we'll see you in hell my movie
podcast with Pat Walsh we are over at
we'll see uh I'm sorry we're at
patreon.com
wsiyhpodcast you can get all the new
episodes there and the back catalog is
available online wherever you get your
podcasts and finally Joey Rose's my barn
sandwich shop is now open seven days a
week at 11 30 a.m every day drinks and
sandwiches all day long come through
thank you for the support we've turned a
year old I can't believe we made it this
is amazing thank you guys we couldn't
have done it without you come see us and
if you want info about the bar and
sandwich shop Joey roses NY ic.com thank
you
taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds man yeah they're coming
folks welcome to t-a-s-d-e buds oh I'm
in the hot seat over here I'm in I
switched chairs for this episode I'm
over here we have our guests
the guys we [ __ ]
not the guys we [ __ ] the guy was gonna
say the guys we [ __ ] gals then I
thought gals was derogatory and I
thought about it up here yeah it's more
just we we need people to know our names
because it's gonna say guys we [ __ ]
girls on our gravestone we don't want
that
door will be embedded with the guys we
[ __ ] yeah yeah I was gonna say the
guys we [ __ ] gals Christina Hutcherson
Korean Fisher and then I got tripped up
on saying gals and then when I got
tripped I thought I was like now it says
like I'm saying your guys that we [ __ ]
right saying I was a wee right you're
saying I have a dick you're coming out
as non-winning area
right right right so well we're already
in shambles okay uh Korean Fisher
Christina Hutcherson uh and and and I I
mentioned guys we [ __ ] just to give
the credit to to the credit of one of
the things the many things you do but
more importantly your friends and I'm
glad you're here I'm really happy you're
both here thank you so happy to be here
back back in the scene of one of my
favorite thanksgivings yes yes clown
painting which is terrible terrifying
yeah it's a little scary Christina and I
had a uh Thanksgiving
um in this apartment yeah in for covid
you were I was stuck here I couldn't see
my family because you covet and uh I
didn't want to see my family you didn't
want to see your family not because of
it yeah but that was the case and you
came over and um and we just we ate
fried chicken we made oh it's white
trash thanks white trash Thanksgiving we
microwaved a lot of the food a lot of a
lot of fried chicken mac and cheese is
[ __ ] cranberry sauce from the can
video games it's amazing yes yes smoked
cigarettes we drank we drank we smoked
cigarettes I remember and then I
remember you had to leave because you
and Wendy Starling had a zoom show to do
oh right we had like a zoom glamor puss
probably yeah and there's nothing
lonelier than when you're having a
Thanksgiving with one other person
because you can't see your family
because of covid and you drink and then
that person leaves and then you're
[ __ ] with all of the all the trash
all the boxes
in the middle of the video game you're
like I don't I don't know I guess I'll
just drink yeah I'll just drink by
myself yeah you couldn't go to a bar at
that point no yeah everything was closed
that was like lockdown winter what did
you do that Thanksgiving
um I believe my dad was dying so I was
okay that's why you weren't with us all
right cool cool yeah that'll that'll
take everything over on the zoom Zoom
wasn't I on
Zoom show you did around there because
you had like a nativity oh we did a
nativity play that was me and Donna
Guerrero oh okay because I was like I
was on something Christmas night that
was Christmas you said you were gonna
try I remember you had said you were
gonna try to come back and meet and like
meet us but then you got tied up you
didn't you never made it oh sorry I
don't remember
I hate Thanksgiving it's my number one
least favorite day of the year so I just
black out on Thanksgiving not from
drinking just from my own just in my
mind I just don't like the day it's just
historically gone very poorly for me
same honestly I found the key though you
have it with friends [ __ ] family no
family I mean if you have a good
relationship with your family what you
do don't like the day I just I would
just like to see I I would love to like
treat it the way Luke treats his dad's
death yearly on Gilmore Girls
like it's not happening and no one hears
from me on that day okay maybe I go
fishing at a lake by myself I obviously
don't catch anything I wouldn't do
animal cruelty right no books um you
just throw worms into the water what
does Luca go fishing no Luke the
character from Gilmore Girl no no but
it's just Luca go fishing because you
said maybe go fishing by yourself yeah
no Luke goes fishing on Gilmore Girls a
lot yeah that's like his quiet place
that's a bummer of a song yeah it is
when you learn what it's about because
it's so beautiful and then you're like
this is about a kid getting beat
upstairs I thought Another Day in
Paradise was about a vacation that went
bad nope no it's about poverty that was
a period of like pop songs hitting the
airwaves that had real heavy heavy to a
light tune yeah yeah like Phil Collins
had a string of this is about a homeless
man like dying real big yeah yeah ah
yeah and like Luca was from then
um
even that time period even when they
weren't like um
like I don't know that was just a weird
that's one time Tom's Diner came out
I love that song you've always bumped me
out really what there was just something
about the bum what you Associated it
with something and you're like I had a
diner alone yeah Tom Tom is your teacher
what do you think I would love to like
when I see people sitting at a diner
alone I go fingers crossed do you uh do
you remember uh
we're so different I uh I listen I'm
with I do before we get too far away
from Thanksgiving I want to relate to
you
it's hard so yeah
it's uh
horrible Thanksgiving this year and I
thought the same thing in fact on my way
home I called Christina because I was
like calling her to be like hey I don't
know if you're around and you want to do
it let's try a regular of drinking on
Thanksgiving but like I'm on my way home
I'm I am miserable right now outside
hotline yeah she was tied up so I drank
alone again in the apartment okay
it was sort of a replay
um but yeah Thanksgiving kind of does
suck I think I'm just gonna do it the
ones I've done with friends it's just
been fun like yeah I don't know why
we're friends with comedians or deal why
would you not have a Thanksgiving full
of comedians that's the best thing ever
just like all the cooking too I mean
like I I actually like cooking but it's
like we're all like working so hard to
cook the same meal as everybody else on
Instagram that doesn't appeal to me yeah
I don't take pictures of it because I'm
like I'm doing this for me you know well
I just like to see pictures like if it's
like to me it's like if you painted a
painting you know you would take a
picture yeah I don't cook anything that
good so nothing's really funny I did a
full Thanksgiving myself from top to
bottom oh right and there was a lot of
yelling
by you or by uh
it was how quickly you turn into a wife
it was incredible the food was so good I
mean soup from scratch appetizers I did
everything so much prep but then I made
my boyfriend and my parents uh just sit
I said you go talk to each other in the
living room and I'll do this things were
breaking that's great but I did it I
just wanted to prove to myself that I
could do it uh I I I'm just I'm similar
in the kitchen I get very yelly very
Gordon Ramsay yeah you were pretty calm
when we were microwaving [ __ ] but that's
because it's not a lot going on I
wouldn't have let you see that side of
me yeah yeah I wouldn't let many people
see that no he saves that for me yeah
yeah it's all for Korean I get it yeah
it's um and and we and then just I want
to plug the other show yeah well because
this is fun because it's relevant
because we used to do it together it was
relevant what happened why did you don't
do it together Joe didn't want to yell
as much so he had to leave without a
country so that he could yell about bon
bons I know I was yeah it was one
stressor replaced with another it was
you don't understand how hard I laughed
Joe when I was like yeah when you saw
the new podcast he had to leave for
mental health and then I just been
flipping through Instagram and then he's
yelling at myself can we please just
talk about fried Twizzlers we had to
start doing Xiao makes fun of me I made
him start doing this chant with me where
we said no matter what happens I love
you because we would get so heated and I
was like I can't I'm taking too much of
this you can take any topic and make it
the highest Stakes thing for you we did
what's a skill it's why you shine as a
comedian yeah so why you're gonna die
young yeah and we're all worried about
you I know high stakes baby
it's tough it's tough we're worried I
know well you're worried and you're the
best one who gives speeches out of all
of us so who's gonna talk when you die
every stand-up clip he posts is just
like nurses
this [ __ ] [ __ ] comes in
uh oh and I got bit by the way I got you
guys will appreciate this I got banned
from Texas of course you did was it
because of the nurses drama we think I
was allowed back I was following it I
was allowed back in I was banned though
I was fully banned for three days and
then somebody knew somebody Venetia knew
somebody and and they got it reversed
but like I appealed it and they were
like no you're banned what'd you do um
in a nutshell I got this nurse thing
went sideways on me this bit that got
posted it like it it went viral in a way
I've never had anything go viral I got
trolled in a way that I've never been
trolled it was fishing
yeah rape threats death threats here's
your address here's the front door of
your apartment building I know a guy
yeah I got death threats and I got I got
I didn't get any rape threats but I got
death threats and I got uh I got uh fake
one star reviews of my restaurant which
was very hurtful that's really terrible
because I really
but they were fake they weren't real
they were fake but a lot some of them we
were able to have removed because you're
like these are this is fake this person
was never there but you can't really
prove that yeah Savvy but anyway
um
uh uh but but but
um oh oh so that started all this stuff
on if you Google my name in Tick Tock
it'll be pages of just the response
videos to to the nurse stuff what'd you
say you're anti-nurse in a way you were
like making fun of nurses famous nurse
spit okay that's my famous version
nurses and teachers and bicycling I've
learned yes trouble with bicycling
Twitter
bicyclists yeah I made it I got in
trouble boarding on the last episode I'm
sure that's going to bite me in the ass
yeah I mean people are just wow
right now because I it's in my there's a
whole thing about it in my new hour and
I want to leave it for that but if
people want to look it up they can but
anyway the point is is they
um
I like that Joe is positioning himself
to be uh to nurses what Dave Chappelle
is to trans people
all right just lean in and never loosen
up that there's I admire it there's your
resp I think the response of my thing is
not you'll see you'll see there's a
reason why JoJo Rosa was my favorite
comedian yeah it is anymore because like
I know you it feels too weird yeah no I
know well listen I love you we love each
other are we gonna do the chat now okay
we do the chat I love you man wait why
did I but wait a minute oh oh because so
so the the the fervor around that I
guess caught the attention of some of
the folks over Tick Tock and then two of
my videos got the two that we put up
after that got pulled damn uh
so the first one got booted and I was
like we were kind of like I guess I
can't why that one got booted like I
make a joke in it about a gun like maybe
that's why I got voted I got some gun
stuff taken off I was just literally
shooting a gun and didn't think that you
could not post that oops even if in a
place where it's legal like you can't oh
yeah no can't just shoot a rifle in Utah
like an America we're so repressed what
the [ __ ] and then a second thing got
booted and then the third and then we
just started putting up clips from taste
buds because we were like we're getting
too many things booted yeah they just
Banned Me we were like what is going on
and then somebody in the office just
reversed it because it's like politics
exactly none of it none of this means
anything if you know somebody on the
force you'll get out of the ticket yeah
like it's just literally all it is like
it's so
but you gotta you were shooting a gun
legally and it got pulled
and it said and it said because you're
not allowed to like I think you're not
allowed to show rifles on camera
yeah yeah like to me I'm thinking I'm
like well what if you had like it's like
you can own guns in America so it's like
what if it was an instructional video
about gun safety yeah it seems like you
should be able to my Instagram clip just
got pulled down because it was a joke
that was where I was I was joking about
the the joke was I tried cocaine did I
like it no I [ __ ] loved it right and
then I make jokes about like here's what
cocaine does when you do it they got
pulled because they said uh it it
supported the intent to distribute uh
drugs or legal supplements that's crazy
that would have been
I got a Google her for my name and it
was a it was a porn site clicked the
link it was it was like crimfish or
Christina Hudson it was a bunch of porn
and I'm like uh oh what happened but we
weren't on the actual link it was weird
but I posted it because I thought it was
funny and I forgot to cover up one of
the vaginas and like 800 men messaged me
and there's like there's a [ __ ] in
there that you didn't cover up I'm like
wow wait I've got good eye and then
Instagram events Instagram eventually
took it down it was clickbait they think
we're a lot more clickable well I
learned that you can show female nudity
in the context of giving birth so I can
show a [ __ ] if there's a baby coming
out of it which I 100 plan to do cut to
me with my dog layer like this he's got
a little toupee on
covered in slime I know I'll ask you
this and by the way what I'm about to
ask if you want it cut we'll just cut it
out because I don't know if it's
something I get it if you're like don't
say that because it'll make people
whatever but I'm just curious
uh have you guys had people face swap
you into porn yet no because that's
I want I would oh you want that oh okay
see what it looks like well did they do
a good job porn sites maybe I could get
some tips this is how this is so bad
that this is a thing now this is so bad
there are now apps that they're
advertising on porn sites where they're
like look how easy it is and they show
you the face swap in real time
it's disgusting it's over the world
where it's it's but at that I don't know
what's gonna happen next that's so gross
then it's okay a nude who gives a [ __ ]
there's me getting railed by eight dudes
in the ass but it's face swap but no
one's gonna know the difference so at
that point it's like it's almost like
the world is going to [ __ ] so badly that
like nothing really matters it's kind of
more relaxing that way someone face swap
me into Star Wars as Princess Leia
that's a good one well that's nice that
was sweet
it was like it was no just like uh
um no not just like I don't know it's
just a scene where she's running around
and I was like oh that's a really good
accurate one that's great accurate face
well I excuse me I remember when the
Deep fake and face swap thing first
started happening
like first started happening and
everybody was like posting things or
whatever and I remember my friend Scotty
Landis who's a really talented writer
and a good guy he tweeted something I'm
paraphrasing like yeah guys yeah this is
really [ __ ] great like being like and
he was the first one I saw call it out
and I was like holy [ __ ] he is so on the
money with this right now and he'll get
no credit as being the first guy
probably that said anything negative
about this on Twitter
um and but he was right it's like dude
yeah it's barreled out of you can't what
the fact that you can't watch a news
clip of the president speaking and know
if it's real or not oh that sucks I'm
staying out of the news I don't know
about that no but I mean it's just
that's how good it is now yeah like they
were okay it turned out to be fake news
funny enough but they released this new
story about deep Bruce okay so they have
this thing I feel like this is without a
country like the early years I've missed
you
I needed Christina this is
there's so many news stories I'll see
every week where I'm like I wish I was
on the show
but uh
[Music]
I can like report in like this is what I
thought about this yeah
okay yes oh my God pretend you died you
get so much press oh that'd be great
but so okay so there's a thing now that
they do which you know to in in theory
this is kind of cool in its own way but
it's not good
they have a thing that they can do now I
forget what the technology is called
where you go in
any one of us could go in and you say a
bunch of stuff into a microphone and
they take it and they are able to create
fake fake generate your voice saying
anything so the best example of it
[ __ ] serious dead serious so the best
example is is James Earl Jones went in
to lucasfilm and did this so they can
use his voice forever for Darth Vader
forever like there will never now be a
Darth Vader where it's not James Earl
Jones and he gets money and whatever and
blah blah blah blah right because but it
goes beyond saying all the like they can
then manipulate all of it and I they're
like can you say Jews are bad we might
go a different direction
Jews are good cookies are bad and we're
just gonna take that and run forever but
like there's videos online of it of how
it works like from the company like you
know it was like I think it's just a
startup company but it's amazing
technology and they show you they're
like here's how this can bend and what
and it's very very brilliant
mind-blowing technology
is it good in the sense that like James
Earl Jones voluntarily is like I can
forever be Darth Vader now and the fans
will be happy yeah that's great
but obviously it's going to be bad for a
lot of other reasons and it's to the
point now that's just one element of the
deep fake whatever stuff a new story
broke that turned out to be fake news
where it's set because Bruce Willis
retired because he's got that condition
where you can't I forget what it's
called
[Laughter]
turns out he had it the whole time
that's so funny uh so he uh but he
retired and then it said there was a
headline said Bruce Willis is the first
actor to sell his likeness to to make
deep fake movies where they'll be able
to use him
[Music]
well here's the thing so his team came
out two days later and said this is not
true we did not do this
now here's this is the troubling part to
me whether he did it or not doesn't
matter we all believed it was possible
because it is possible number one and
then number two did his team come out
and say we didn't do this because they
didn't do it or did they come out and
say we didn't do this because it was bad
press yeah they were like oh we [ __ ]
up right
every part of that story to me
epitomizes like this is where we're
headed this is how bad it is
that's [ __ ] terrifying you're missing
one thing I just Googled that and uh
Russia a Russian company has run away
with this idea and it's just started
releasing commercials starring famous
American actors oh my God and they don't
care
Bruce Willis were in like uh commercial
together in Russia that's really holy
[ __ ] wow holy [ __ ] so we're not even
gonna have control of our likeness they
can make Blockbusters and just drop it
and go this one's better dude Russia
doesn't give a [ __ ] they don't I respect
that they don't care about it they don't
care she Jesus oh my God
they don't care yeah they don't they do
whatever the [ __ ] they wanted to say
yeah I kind of want to watch it too like
when Trump does it you're like I kind of
want to do it yeah I see it I mean we
thought North Korea was bad right yeah
Russian food is like yeah hold my my
vodka
um
are truffles Russian is that a Segway oh
wow that's a half a Segway yeah
are they Russian I would say sounds like
a Russian word I don't think they're I
don't think they're Russian but no right
no idea well we're the arguments I found
in nature but I don't and I wouldn't
think they would grow because Russia
would is cold so I don't think there's a
lot of growing like fungus fungi there
you know you could say it with less tone
I'm joking around I know I know um the
um so so uh
uh we'll plug everything again at the
End by the way too um but um well let's
do the battle the battle today before I
start it just explain to fans
um we're doing truffle yay or nay this
is a new format we do
okay so originally the show was only
ever this thing versus that thing right
and then we started to realize well wait
a second you can actually just argue
Pros or cons against one thing and it's
still a poll that you can put on Twitter
and it's still an argument so this is
that format
um and it's just truffle it's the idea
of truffle it's probably going to be a
little more about truffle flavor than
anything else
um because I don't think a lot of people
and the fungi not the candy just to be
very close oh yes yes geez oh [ __ ] it's
a mushroom [ __ ] did we did we specify
that do you think people understood they
must truffle's so popular right now well
I was hoping because like you know if
it's if you've had a lot of white trash
audience they might think it's like a
candy yeah I like that who knows yeah
talking about the elegant I prefer the
candy in the Box yeah who especially
after Ian last week that was crazy
what's that after eating last week with
his interpretation of our poll Ian was
oh that was one of the craziest things
I've ever in my life oh Ian did
something zany wow out of characters
what happened Ian Lara and I battle oh
I was like send me the food you hate or
love he goes and one of his hates was no
white sauces ever like I hate white
sauce right okay so it's like oh we
could do and he and then he put that he
loved pizza and I was like oh we could
do white sauce versus red sauce that's
like a good battle and like you know
it's like an Italian restaurant bottle
and I was like you know I like red sauce
better but I could argue for white sauce
because because you get you know clam
sauce and all these other things and um
and then we started doing it and he was
like he's like I don't I was like so
tell me why you don't like white sauce
it's like right off the bat he was like
I don't like it man it's gross he's like
red sauce is better barbecue sauce
ketchup colors yeah oh my God and what
are you talking about I think I called
him trash I go what are you trying
raspberry jam yeah right he said that
raspberry vinaigrette counted as red
sauce oh
he's stupid and I'm stupid but that's
stupid okay it was insane I was like
what are you talking about dude okay
yeah uh so I gotta meet this guy that
was a crazy interpretation yeah you
ended up arguing White
CR anything liquid and white versus
Tzatziki yeah
mayonnaise yeah yeah mayonnaise was Jake
for him he was he was bigger
he was huge he was huge he's staunchly
anti-man this is
that I found in my personal life
a lot of men see
men
sees
he he addressed the
spermen semen aspect of but whose [ __ ] is
that thick I don't know no one's coming
no better than I was here to say I don't
mean that insulting lady I just mean I
haven't encountered a lot of
not you you not that you've encountered
a lot you've encountered more than I
have not correct yeah and a lot that's
all it can be both
clip it for tick tock
tick tock folks do you like the fantasy
play do you like playing daily fantasy
do you like place and entries do you
like making player projections do you
like doing all that with the sports
prize picks here you go
your daily fantasy app or website check
out prize picks I know you you're
thinking well I want to make a play I
think uh tonight I'm gonna take uh
Patrick uh Mahomes to throw more than
320 passing yards they're Derek Henry to
rush for more than or less than 85 yards
and Cooper cup to score more than 0.5
touchdowns Tyreek Hill even to catch
less than 3.5 passes well you can do
that all at prize pick what will you
love about prize picks if you haven't
used it yet well I'll tell you it's easy
to use it's fun to play there is a slew
of sports to pick from everything you
can possibly think of is on here it's
easy to do the projections you can read
what their projections are and here's
how it works you pick two to six players
if they will go to score more or less
than the prize pick projection that's it
you can win up to 25 times your money on
any entry that's it you're not competing
against other people it's just you
versus the projections available that's
it that's all you got to do folks this
is awesome make your entries in 60
seconds or less it's that easy and you
can do safe and fast withdrawals so
download prize picks uh the app or you
can go to prizefix.com and sign up and
play daily fantasy sports first time
users can receive a hundred percent
instant deposit match up to a hundred
dollars when you use promo code taste
buds that means if you deposit up to a
hundred dollars prize picks will give
you up to a hundred dollars they'll
match you so if you deposit 25 they'll
match you with 25 deposit 50. they'll
give you fit you get it don't forget you
got to enter promo code taste buds at
sign up for an instant deposit match of
up to a hundred dollars prize picks your
daily fantasy stop
folks Joe DeRosa here
and I want to talk to you about this
show being sponsored by betterhelp uh I
love better help I've talked about
better help quite a bit uh on this show
I've talked about it quite a bit off of
this show I am a user of better help I
think that they're just a wonderful
wonderful wonderful crew of people that
are doing the right thing to bring you
the help that you need I think it's
great uh you know here's the thing
you have a lot of stuff thrown at you in
life you have a lot of problems thrown
at you in life and in life you want to
get to a place where you can solve those
problems and not get bogged down or um
or stuck or or tied up in the problems
themselves and being overwhelmed by the
problems you want to be able to actually
get to the solutions to those problems
and that's a tough thing to do because
there is no guidebook there is no set of
instructions to get through life there's
just life and figuring out ways to
navigate it and better help is extremely
helpful if you will in in helping you do
that uh they've connected over three
million people with licensed therapists
it's convenient it's accessible anywhere
and it's a hundred percent online you're
going to get connected with the
therapist that's trained to help you
figure out the cause of challenging
emotions and learn the productive coping
skills you'll need it's going to make
therapy the closest thing to that user
manual we all wish we had in life uh as
the world's largest therapy service
better help us match again three million
people with professionally licensed and
vetted therapists that's important
they're all vetted uh
it's also affordable did I mention that
that's nice uh that that's nice I think
the prices are pretty amazing again as a
user myself so you go you fill out a
brief questionnaire and they match you
up and they get you going and if things
aren't working for you between you and
your therapist that you're linked up
with you can switch anytime you want
couldn't be easier there's no waiting
rooms there's no traffic there's no
endless searching for the right
therapist there's no bureaucratic bull
crap meds whatever system in place to
keep you from getting to where you go
it's all just there to be accessible
affordable and helpful uh and here's the
deal you can save 10 off your first
month at betterhelp.com tastebuds that's
better help better help
better help.com taste buds
somebody had mentioned that it was
homophobic to him
and he said that he didn't this is wild
not liking white sauce right okay
really you can get people on anything
these days okay yeah yeah
he said they weren't direct they weren't
like going out offended about it okay
okay they were just saying like is it
like a is it like a gay thing
varieties
he doesn't like a mayonnaise
uh yeah yeah no the uh but he but yeah
he mentioned that that it was he did say
it's a consistency thing it's kind of
weird I love mayonnaise like I'll put
mayonnaise on a sandwich and then also a
side of mayonnaise and dip the mini
sandwich in more mayonnaise consistency
though I call [ __ ] on that in terms
of like you put mayonnaise on a sandwich
where are you getting the consistency
it's a little slippery but it's a
[ __ ] sandwich unless he's talking
about dipping like a fry I get I get it
because I don't
I I seldomly dip anything in mayonnaise
but I I get it like if I get a sandwich
with too much Mayo I get grossed out
yeah there's so much of anything you
need balance you need that's how I feel
about ketchup like I hate too much
ketchup yeah yeah too much sauce is
gross because then it's boring it's
soggy bread I don't want too much
ketchup but I don't it doesn't gross me
out I'm just like yeah just [ __ ] this
up like you know like right but with
mayonnaise I'm like oh this is like I'm
starting like I'm getting like grossed
out yeah it's not like when you see it
in the bottle it's kind of yucky but I
just remember how good it tastes just
still go with egg salad oh my god well
yeah of course avocado oh my god
um all right wait this is
let's put a pin because this is a good
place to start the Truffle battle
because I have a I have a place we can
start
um okay folks here we go it's Corinne
and I who hate truffle against Christina
who loves truffle time to
b-a-t-t-l-e budge here we go what if I
just punch you guys in the face and then
left did I win I won the battle that
would be incredible actually
my rings I will start with uh
I had we had a bunch of truffle stuff at
one point
um because we had a sponsor called truff
who were good people and they made a
good shot for dudes yeah they made a
good product and I got the one thing I
was happy I got for them was truffle oil
which is very expensive and it was a
nice thing to have on hand for cooking
uh but truff loves to they're big on
infusing flavors the flavor of trough
into other things
um one of them was mayonnaise what would
you think of that I think that makes a
lot of sense because the ranch is
basically like a mayonnaise but with
certain seasonings
yeah yeah it's like it's similar
ingredients but like with it leans more
in the season so to me adding truffle
salts to Ranch it just makes a new
little sauce makes sense well this is
truffle Mayo not truffle Ranch okay well
right yeah but she's in the consistency
I'm saying that it reminds me of a ranch
dressing so like okay truffle truffle
Mayo is like a a flavor of ranch you
know what I mean yeah so would you a
sauce okay so okay I see
I hate aioli I hate any flavored
mayonnaise I I can't I oh that's
interesting I don't mind aioli I love it
once they say there's a there's a
something except horses but if the one
the second they say there's anything
injected into the mail I'm like get it
out of here I don't want it I don't want
it there's a rosemary like Mayo at Palm
Springs yeah you don't like that I love
an artisanal Mayo I love Rosemary too I
I put up I'll barf I don't like Rosemary
flavored things truffle
I was excited when TR I'm not just
saying this to be diplomatic I was
excited when Trump sponsored us I was
excited to get trough products
and it wasn't until
a little while after that I started to
realize I don't like truffle flavor oh
because I was wondering I was like wait
wait I don't I don't I just I again
oil because it's like that's a that's a
nice commodity to have in the kitchen
and the salt
I didn't get any truffle salt uh that's
my favorite you said you put it I want
to quote Corinne on this no you you said
this to me you said Christina said yeah
yeah no I want to quote what your
response was oh God I know Christy
Corinne said she was a little worried
she's like I don't know I feel I you you
express concerned maybe we're gonna gang
up on Christina no I don't give a [ __ ]
no it's food I just know how me and Joe
are and I knew I knew that Joe was gonna
get very heated that's hilarious and you
she said I was worried this would happen
it's gonna be us versus her and I go
don't worry about it Christina said and
I sent the quote let's go I put truffle
salt on everything like let's go
and Corinne said I might need a trash
can
because I'll puke during this discussion
wow you hate truffles
I actually did start dry I was in bed
and I started visceral for you dry
heaving to me when I walk into a
restaurant and I can smell immediately
if they're they have it at my menu item
with truffle on it every [ __ ] idiot
is gonna order it and then the whole
restaurant is gonna smell like purple in
the air like there's nothing worse than
like spending extra money to go to like
a high-end Pizzeria and you walk in and
then you smell truffle because that I
mean I'm actually getting sick right now
even thinking it's like coming up in my
neck if you were killed by truffle by in
a past life that's a I've never well
because here's the thing in terms of
arguing and Battleship you don't like it
then don't [ __ ] eat it like you know
you argue that you're wrong
items in a metropolitan City like New
York
why would you put it on pizza or french
fries two of the purest simple Beauties
in the world
truffle flavor and french fries it makes
me Furious and it is a it is it is a
Frack guy food meaning it is loud it's
obnoxious right it's there's no way
around it's like Dill the thing
when Dale goes in the wrong thing you're
like get this out of here
dill salad oh but this is why I was
excited when Corrine started talking
about puking ooh
nuking no I got excited because
not even one of my favorite thing about
Korean is because probably because I
relate to it is she gets
she'll have like real hard opinions
about very like Pastor things yeah yeah
thoughts about non-issues about like the
best Jonas brother
my favorite thing was I was going to
save this till whenever the next one was
on guys we [ __ ] was but like I'll say
it now that's that's your choice
anytime I'll say it I'll say it now uh
and I'll say it too if I remember in the
show again but like it was now I love
that I love I love that I love the
pivots no no I'm not we did uh we did uh
we we got a sponsor without a country
for bidets oh and Mike Mike um
Harrington Harrington texted us on the
threatening goes he goes good news guys
we have a new sponsor pick out which
free bidet you want and I was like oh
awesome that's a great deal and Corinne
just writes back
um I actually hate bidets so I'll pass
and I was like what do you what I just
wrote back I'm not gay
hahaha I was like it's such a weird
thing to hate
but
I used to have a hard stance on whether
or not you like like water up your ass
and your anus is not a crazy thing it's
not that it's not that crazy it was just
funny it was it made me laugh it was
like this is because I was really
excited yeah yeah I was like oh this is
so Jazz because I also thought by the
way I thought it was going to be like
like a true like a bidet bidet because I
saw the ones they had at gas digital
that had like like yeah and it was like
this thing where it was just like
there's like a dial the gas digital toy
that's my favorite toilet yeah it's an
amazing toilet
um anyway
it's pretty it was pretty dirty
yesterday so it's not my favorite toilet
right now but was it warm I don't I my
ass has never touched the seat in gas
digital I spot I guess digital I like it
rubbed my ass party
toilet seat I go yeah no there's uh it's
high and it's very hard for me if I love
it because because I have to go like
this oh yeah that's hard to squat over
there's so many there's so many
personalities over there where you're
like I don't want to sit on this toilet
after that person appearance is bliss
you just don't think about it uh yeah
Lewis is just the beginning of your
problems over there when Louis is the
ass you hope was most on there before
you right that's a bad sign
a lot of interns going in and out
there with the Corinthian or the on-dair
talent yeah trash all around God the uh
uh all right so
but wait but truffle I I think first of
all let me just say the obvious here
they made a movie about truffles
starring Nicholas Cage where a pig a pig
is the pl uh Chris De Stefano hunts
these things that's what hunts travels
um
babe over here babe
oh the Stefano you [ __ ] pig all right
yeah
it's I've just never seen a more valued
thing that I it's like cats like Beanie
Babies gross yeah it's gross but it's
like it's so valued like what why well
just because I think people have a
misconception just because something is
hard to uh acquire or find it doesn't
mean it's good right like are we gonna
start like sauteing four-leaf clovers no
you could though when people would buy
it exactly you can manipulate
[ __ ] into doing anything I
think that's a real thing actually all
you have to do that series I think
there's no sauteed there's a place that
puts a four-leaf like one of the
Michelin whatever uh not Michelin stars
there's the others we have a child from
Turkey
so you won't let him inside until he
finds
there's a place it's not Michelin star
that's the wrong term because that's
what the chefs and restaurants get
there's that there's those there's that
rating of restaurants the globally where
it's like there's only like five
restaurants around the globe yeah that
have like this rating uh-huh um and I
think one of them if I'm not mistaken I
know one of them
and we tried to get in when we were in
uh
I think it was in Denmark we couldn't
get in and I was really bummed that we
couldn't get in that I I think that one
has a dish with live ants on it oh I can
see it but like but yeah but they but
anyway I think one of them does like a
four literally puts a four-leaf clover
on the dish like that's kind of part of
it see you can dream it yeah yeah a
shaving of a unicorn's Tusk yeah well
they were mine okay so like truffles
remind me a lot of this phenomenon in
Hollywood boutiques so I you know I
watch a lot of like reality nonsense but
one thing that happens in Hollywood
boutiques is if they're having trouble
selling an item instead of putting it on
sale they'll make the price higher to
trick people into buying it to me that
is truffles it's a trick I just think
that everybody said this is a delicacy
now and if you are a high uh brow person
you you will like this your palette will
accept this and I think people truffles
feel trick themselves it's like you're
believing that if they're somebody they
have to like the taste of truffle and I
said no yes there is there is an aspect
of it too now where where do you ever
see um so there's two things all
referred you ever see Small Time Crooks
the Woody Allen movie with Tracy Allman
damn no it was like one more element we
haven't seen the uh well it's it's a
funny movie but it's part of the plot is
that they suddenly become they're like
very blue collar and they suddenly
become very rich okay and Tracey Ullman
is she's brilliant in it and she's like
this lady from Queen she's very like oh
my God like you know she's like one of
those and um and then she like throws
this party
for like the elite uh-huh and they all
like are laughing at her because like
she thinks she understands what class is
but she just it's it's not she's just
gaudy and right whatever but she just
buys things because so one of the things
she does at the meal is she's like yell
she's like on the chef she's like to do
I want finger bowls
and he's like we're not serving anything
that requires finger she's like put him
put up and then she actually sits with
the Truffle she goes she goes and with
the shave truffles don't be shy Go baby
go go yeah um because she just wants to
show she thinks that means she'll be
accepted right and I feel like
truffle is that because it's now making
its way into regular Supermarket life it
used to be this thing where you had to
go to like some sort of Gourmet Market
or specialty store or whatever and now I
feel like you can kind of go into a
regular supermarket and see a truffle
something or other
you know something a place you might
shop well well a lot of grocery stores
in my area don't have truffle salt so I
actually haven't had it in a while
because I can't [ __ ] find it why
don't you order it online I could I like
catching it in the wild like um
babe there's a job here babe
oh my God you on the ground trying to
step out truffle salt not truffles just
in the grocery store yeah package
troubles oh that's a good visual I think
we need to make it happen yeah I think
that should happen yeah it's funny
um but no I I do think so I do think
that's a little part of it right right
because they did that with remember when
Godiva Chocolate suddenly became like
this thing that you could just couldn't
get anywhere you know such a joke you
can get it at Marshalls yeah exactly
yeah and it means nothing anymore I got
it for someone at Marshall's because I
was like they're not gonna know yeah
right on the cover that was like a thing
if that was going on that Marshall's
sticker how long ago was that like a
thing though well I remember I worked in
the 2000s like I think I worked at the
fancy mall in New Jersey do we have a
good diet that they all had Godiva
Godiva ice cream to me was like the
Touch of Elegance it's like oh you're at
Baskin Robbins you're at Haagen-Dazs
poor [ __ ] Haagen-Dazs like actually go
into the store but if you got Godiva in
the cone I mean hello yeah yeah when I
was a kid Haagen-Dazs was was like
I mean you could get it but it was
considered like it was considered like
high-end ice cream can you get
Haagen-Dazs in this neighborhood well I
worked at the Short Hills Mall which is
a very bougie mall in New Jersey and
because of our uh we don't really have
taxes on certain amounts of clothes I
mean I think the laws have changed since
then in New York but like a lot of
celebrities used to come to get like
Gucci and stuff at Short Hills mall so
they wouldn't have to pay the New York
City taxes
um so that's the kind of Mall it was but
there was a Haagen-Dazs there and it was
so bougie that they didn't even sell ice
cream cones because they said ice cream
cones were tacky and you couldn't have
people walking around the Short Hills
mall with ice cream might as well eat it
off the floor only Haagen-Dazs and only
hagen-dazs from become a cup
yeah yeah that's very interesting well I
mean there's there's it's it sorry it's
my doctor messaging me um folks let's
discuss
rocket money rocket money uh now here's
what I like about rocket money let me
just say a little bit about myself I am
somebody that uh often uh is spending
money maybe even wasting money if you
will uh on subscriptions that I
completely forgot about I see a ton of
subscriptions every day constantly uh
online things getting offered to me I
want to subscribe to this and try this
thing out whatever
they're coming at you hard and fast all
the time in this culture and I sign up
for these things and I forget and it
leads to a loss of money that I
shouldn't be spending eighty percent of
people
are also doing this uh you know and
whatever maybe it's your unused Amazon
Prime account maybe it's Hulu and you're
never watching it or whatever
it doesn't matter rocket money is a
great app
and it helps me track all of my expenses
uh and I no longer waste money on
subscriptions I'm not using uh it's
great it's great it's great uh rocket
money by the way used to be called true
bill that's when I first heard of it now
it's called Rocket money uh do you know
how much your subscriptions really cost
by the way most Americans think they
spend around eighty dollars a month on
subscriptions well actually it's closer
to 200 or more
that's right you could be wasting
hundreds of dollars each month on
subscriptions you don't even know about
that's enough use this app fix it I'm
telling you do this the app will show
you all the subscriptions you have in
one place and then it'll cancel for you
whatever you don't want anymore that's
all rocket money can even find
subscriptions you didn't know you were
even paying for you may even find out
you're being double charged for a
subscription which can happen because
you could sign up in one place through
one service and then also sign up
somewhere else and then it it's nuts get
a get a handle on this thing all right
get rid of the useless subscriptions
with rocket money use it now go to
rocketmoney.com tastebuds
seriously this could save you hundreds
hundreds of dollars per year that's
rocketmoney.com taste buds cancel the
unnecessary subscriptions right now with
rocketmoney.com taste buds
fellas do you sometimes need a little
confidence boost in the bedroom we've
all had those moments maybe you had a
little too much to drink maybe you're
too nervous maybe your head's just
somewhere else I don't know but it
happens and there's nothing worse than
not being able to put
the stick shift wink wink and drive when
you need it the most but I have no fear
Rex MD is here
spread and cheer even for when you've
had too many beers you get where I'm
going with this Rex MD is an FDA
approved that's important they're FDA
approved and they're the most trusted
leader in men's Telehealth they
sponsored our episode to help you always
be prepared Rex MD has made it simple
easy and cost effective to help men out
there last longer and feel more
confident in the bedroom
they're making getting the generic and
branded Viagra or Cialis easy
everything's online even the
prescription and that means it's
discrete gets delivered discreetly to
your door there's no waiting rooms
there's no embarrassing trips to the
doctor there's no insurance there's no
co-pays this is just a great discreet
deal for you to get the assistance you
might need uh take advantage of the best
deal they've ever offered and save up to
90 percent off and only pay two dollars
per dosage with our exclusive link go to
rexmd.com
tastebuds for this limited time deal
they've made the whole process simple
there's no need to jump through a bunch
of Hoops and again set up in setting up
embarrassing doctors appointments and
things of that nature to get your
medication
unlike other brands Rex MD is FDA
approved and clinically tested it's it's
it's this is good stuff you'll be
getting FDA approved Ed treatments at a
90 treatment cheaper rate than your
doctors
all right look act now because it's
starting to get busy
uh take advantage of the best deal
they've ever offered rexmd.com taste
buds that's where you're going to go
rexmd.com tastebuds that's an exclusive
deal that will save you up to 90 off but
you're only going to pay two dollars per
dosage starter packs of generic Viagra
or Cialis are now available for our
listeners to get started that's
rexmd.com tastebuds for up to 90 off
give the gift of pleasure this holiday
season with Rex MD that's very
interesting but that also makes sense
where it's like okay if you want to have
a high-end thing you eliminate certain
uh elements not meaning people just
meaning like No Good Times yeah yeah I
just never crossed my mind anymore and
like at any time I'm like I didn't know
Cones were tacky and it could also drip
everywhere right yeah and then you're
getting your hand you're getting it on
your hands you're you know to me I'm
like uh it seems like you want you mean
no children yeah yeah yeah yeah
um but here's the other thing I was
going to reference is there was so Penn
teller had that show [ __ ] remember
yeah
um they I believe it was actually the
finale of the whole show like I think it
was the last episode they ever did they
did an episode about the the concept of
the best and how the concept of that was
[ __ ] it was it was all just Optics
and they invite all of these like
sophisticates to this restaurant this
fake restaurant that they say is like a
new place that's about to open and the
chef is going to prepare them this meal
whatever and it's all frozen dinners
that's hilarious they make the Frozen
they use they just they just cook the
frozen dinners but then they played it
to make it look like whatever Stouffer's
I'd be all over oh Stouffer's and they
but they don't tell them that it's
frozen dinners they right they you know
they presented yeah it's a gourmet meal
and the waiters like and he's saying
that he's saying I think I can't
remember if he says if he makes up
ingredients or not but he's just
describing the food and in a gourmet way
and they all think it's real they all
think it's real and he and they talk
about like the phenomenon of like
do they actually think it's good like do
they do they not want to seem like
they're not classy and high-end so
they're agreeing when they don't think
it's yeah they should be other people
saying things like they don't know you
know
anyway there's that's what truffles are
all right I mean I think there's a
reason only animals can find them
specifically pigs yeah it's like oh you
like like dogs dogs all can also hunt
them and I was like Oh you mean the same
creature that sniffs my crotch yeah good
taste he has good taste I would say you
know why is it that only pigs can sniff
out truffles these things stink like
[ __ ] every time they're out in a
restaurant why is it so hard for
anything everybody to smell these things
or identify them well I guess because
pigs are lower to the ground so that's
like they have to I think it's like to
actually get where they are and dig them
up I will say this and I said this to
you over text Joe truffle salt when I
put it on [ __ ] it does make it kind of
taste like a sweaty sock in a way that I
like
I don't know where what else to tell you
like I get why you can't I think she
likes truffle the same way I like people
will be like how do you like aperol and
I'm like there's just some it and I I
recognize it tastes like cleaning fluid
it tastes like you're drinking fabuloso
and that's what I was looking for in a
beverage
listen it's weird sometimes you want to
punch yourself all the time about I'm
very particular with olive oil because
like uh you know we use olive oil a lot
at Joey roses uh and I use olive oil a
lot at home uh but I have to use a very
particular olive oil because otherwise
olive oil to me tastes like cat piss
yeah it can I'm like this smells like
that piss to me if it's not the right
you know what I mean right right Pepsi
also there's something about Pepsi that
it tastes a little bit like urine but I
don't mind I get so offended when a
restaurant only has Pepsi I agree we
argue Pepsi versus Coke on the show it
was one of the most meds I've ever got
at South because he was defending Pepsi
disgusting find out why pigs like
truffles there's a sex hormone found in
the Truffle that the male pigs like I
like it yeah they're aphrodisiac
you know what I'm always horny so it
makes sense that I love truffles we
should call anything to make me more
horny I'm in let's call Chris on air I
can't think of anything that would make
me less horny than someone's mouth
tasting like truffle oh God give it to
me Rose every time I even like like even
I can like remember the the smell in my
head I'm like wow yeah it tastes like
I've never had it what does it even
taste like it's like a sweaty sock I
gotta say like a really sticky cheese to
me I also get like a monster cheese and
to me they have they have a similar
response for me it's funny you say that
I like monster cheese but I never before
I could well I don't put on I just I
sometimes I would eat it like slice yeah
no that's how I referred it like in my
head I like I think of like monster
cheese is like the cheese that like
ruined a marriage like it's like it's a
wow right right right but I also find
monster monster to me is also like like
I like it but like it seems like a
trashy cheese to me there's something
about muenster cheese
it smells so bad like I think I wanted
my ordered a sandwich and I didn't read
it the description properly on the menu
and monster was on it and I cried
I have never in my life and I'm dead
serious whatever place that was don't go
back I've never seen a place melt
monster cheese on it yeah yeah because I
mean and then the whole like the the
wafting smell follows the waiter as
their brains I've literally never seen
or heard of it like that's wild that's
that's a place try to be original you
know who puts monster cheese on
sandwiches and this is all you need to
know Justin silver
wow
I wouldn't have thought that I wouldn't
have thought that either I thought he
was racist he's usually classier he will
put Monster cheese on a sandwich
put Monster cheese on a sandwich it's
not my first choice but it could be my
second I've never even seen it in
Sandwich form I have only ever seen it
in that little Cabo you're going to the
dairy aisle and it's monster cheese is
one of the
size
and swiss monterey jack provolone all
these cheeses would come before I'd
spray cheese from a can on the sandwich
before I love cheese whiz I don't mind a
bit of monster but I I wouldn't put it
on a sandwich
um it and there is a consistency to
monster where it's just this side of
firm where it doesn't it's like if you
had a piece of it like sandwich size
piece you you would be like this is
supposed to be more firm than it is and
that's what your brain is saying and
it's too soft
we made a whole podcast about it
um but but like but like wait you asked
for truffle tasted like yeah yeah
truffle
it is a there is a sweatiness to it oh a
gym stock I think isn't accurate yeah
what a gym socks smells like it tastes
like that eating that yeah what age did
you all try truffle like when did you
try 29 30. okay okay I didn't know I had
never heard of it until I was 20.
because it was only I feel like it's
only become popular in the past 10 years
yeah so like I love going to wine bars
and they'll [ __ ] a lot of their [ __ ] up
by just sprinkling truffle on it can you
just before the chef does that can you
take it do that yeah and bring it out to
me honestly I didn't have it until it
made its way into common whatever like
truffle I think truffle fries I had
truffle fries that usually have I think
the stand yeah
truffle fries yes but they but they did
it right they put fries and regular
fries yes yes because they understand
that truffle's not for everybody yeah
they put cheese on the fries yes
I love their truffle fries but also
being like I'm not always in the mood
for this and then like that in not in
the mood got bigger and bigger until I
was like I don't like truffle I'm never
in a mood for that yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah were we just like I feel like
I stepped no no I was just thinking more
about how I hate travel I also like if
you wanna I think like you know your
eyes are the first thing that kind of
get you hungry for something and if you
look at a truffle in its full form it's
repulsive it looks like something the
Commodities Museum and then you slice it
open and it's when you slice it open it
looks like the inside of a serial
Killer's brain which I did see at bodies
the exhibition it looks like a break see
I'd rather not know yeah I'd rather just
not see that as well and it's weird like
it's not I don't know why I love
mushrooms mushrooms are my favorite
vegetables Imagine Dragons I don't know
what we're calling it I call it
vegetable because you put in a salad but
I'm sure that's not accurate um
I like mushrooms I don't I don't often
put them in salad though I love them
there was like there's a restaurant
called the office a chain restaurant in
Jersey and they are one of the only
restaurants that includes raw mushrooms
in their salad and I think it makes all
the difference it used to do a
house-made ranch
you're right
okay don't don't please don't show me Oh
I thought you were anyways don't show me
my my raw mushrooms and salad you're
ailing whatever I imagine it looks like
the belly button of a newborn right
before it falls off
it also like the outside of it kind of
looks like a cow's nose that needs to be
hydrated what so it's pink oh well no
there's there's like I think it's a cow
with a black nose because I think cows
can have different color noses depending
on what their
it looks like it looks like
um
it looks like the
um like when a severe alcoholic their
nose like when it gets the little bumps
yeah what's that called The Gin Blossom
nose yeah it looks like this is not red
yeah that's yeah that's what Gin Blossom
means
um yeah like WC Fields like his nose was
like right bumpy that's where the
Truffle looks like this is so gross this
is a good explanation yeah I think
that's it for me I don't think I'll ever
eat truffle ever again oh lot of people
in the comments are saying it's for rich
people are we live it is no well we said
the poll out but look I'm literally
going to truffle prices here hold on
I'm seeing here yeah
[ __ ] I went to buy pine nuts 22
[ __ ] dollars yeah pine nuts are
pricey
gold in them what the hell go to
nuts.com and get better nut prices okay
I used to make really trail mix because
I'm allergic to almonds so I have to
make my own because every trail mix
includes almonds right and so I just
went over to nuts.com I put some Brazil
nuts in I love a Brazil nut I love a
Brazil nut good or Bonnie truffles
two that was this brand of truffles yeah
or body truffles this is an online you
can buy there they are a lot large
excuse me five ounce piece five ounces
take let's take a guess here
five ounces I'm really bad at math
eighty dollars
keep going higher 120
. keep going
275.00 not even close
five ounces
now I'm getting mad 450. what do these
people wipe their ass with money what
the [ __ ] well this is your thing I buy
it in Salt form I buy in salt for how
much is truffle salt I'm broke now so I
don't wait no let's stay on the Truffle
first hold on so four it's more than 450
for five ounces that's a thousand what
that better be a you're not even in the
ballpark two thousand eight hundred
dollars two thousand four hundred ninety
nine dollars five ounces of five ounces
is so small I know of white nick cages
maybe that's a more rare yeah white
truffle I think is more rare than the
other truffle but William Sonoma it's
not two ounces of burgundy truffle from
William Sonoma 130 that's more
reasonable still currently it's all
[ __ ] though I mean two ounces but
then so the Truffle that they're putting
on stuff in restaurants because it's not
that expensive in a restaurant it's only
like it makes things like five dollars
more so it must be some weird
concentrated version the oil down
version of it it can't it's nowhere near
this when you're buying that though so
what the [ __ ] do you do with it do you
dry it out and put like like a like a
grind like a you know like you're
grating cheese like a grater maybe I've
never had I've never like consumed a
full truffle me either it's only been
truffle salt for me oh I've had the oil
and I've had the Truffle shavings and I
it kills me because if it's a meal that
comes with truffle shavings I literally
remove the most expensive part which is
the Truffle shavings right but it's one
of those things that you can still you
can taste that it was there yeah it's in
the room
so much I really didn't know
I'm allergic to onions but I like the
taste of him so I'll get i'll get onions
on a sandwich and then remove them and
then I'll have the flavor of the onion
but I won't get sick but truffle it's
like you have to bring in like a like a
crime scene investigation to get rid of
it time some cleanup and I'm just
reading up I'm I'm listening to you the
only reason I'm looking down is because
I'm trying to find information on
truffles they it looks like they last
about one to three weeks oh wait if
you're looking to preserve your fresh
truffles for one to three months get
them freezing in the freezer so you have
to freeze them if you want to keep them
but it sounds like once they're out in
the fridge you got one to three weeks
which for 25 I mean that's obnoxious
you're dealing with a different level
you wipe your ass with money yeah yeah
you would buy them like for the you know
the the week of the dinner party that
you're having I mean are people just
like having truffles on hand you can can
you harvest
you know chefs at this point I think
you're like hoity 20 if you have an
avocado on hand to me like if I'm if I'm
I'm getting an avocado the day I'm
eating it I'm not waiting around I could
be five dollars just in the garbage
right you're playing right because then
you forget about it pip let's go to the
we're good on time right yeah let's go
to the phones a lot of people have no
idea what the poll is about
seems to be wow
they don't even know what the candy
truffle is a lot of trash listening to
this shop wow that's wow a few people
said Sal your millionaire showing oh
good I like when this happens sometimes
I get them to turn on sour nice good for
being a rich person yeah that [ __ ]
and I like it
does hang with the regulars and it's
nice although I did want to know him at
Soho House yeah
boy he's pulled me in there a few times
I'm not a fan yeah yeah it's it I don't
mind it but it's Soho house it's the
Truffle of yeah clubs I mean come on I
was a member for about two years you're
like I met my grandma's I feel like I'm
not supposed to touch anything yeah I'm
only gonna do something wrong in here
you know and what is it 10 grand a year
to be a member no it's like two grand
okay
all right in front of a child I live
right by Soho House yeah nice maybe I'll
join
us
that sweater is very good for it walk in
with that this is just an old Urban
outfit or sweater or a Lucky Brand
excuse me oh I know I used to think
lucky was bougie too too me too and I
used to see Lucky Brand around there
used to be more they don't have brick
and mortars anymore they do they're
harder to come by now they're not just
around as much you know they're not
doing well because the Lucky Brand
earrings ended up at Marshalls so that's
why I keep tabs on everyone
so that's why I've mentioned it so many
times it's the only place I've they
should sponsor guys uh any food a pig
would sniff out I'm not gonna eat oh
that's cool everyone's kind of just
resigned on this fight a lot of people
saying they don't they don't have an
opinion they've never had it before okay
that's really well let's give the win to
any food a pig would sniff out since
that comes pretty close to the DeStefano
commentary
I'll dig it up I'll retweet them okay
um all right here's how we do it guys we
will you plug then we say the results of
the poll and then whoever wins has to
say I still love you to the loser and
the loser says I love you too and then
we end up that's nice the results seems
to be confusion there's still going to
be water on the pool
yeah
bug away plug away oh I want to plug
guys we [ __ ] the anti-slot training
podcast available on luminary or
wherever you get your podcast and we're
going 10 years strong you could also
watch it on youtube.com guys we [ __ ]
without the unfucked I'm at Christina
Hutch and I have a patreon where I do
monthly group Zoom therapy and quotes
because I'm not a licensed therapist but
it's really [ __ ] fun that's great
amazing okay so also guys we [ __ ]
obviously and then uh without a country
on the gas digital Network it's a
roasting the news show uh old episodes
featuring Joe and you work your way
forward to modern times
if you're around in New York on New
Year's Eve I have a show at 6 PM with
Christina Hutchinson Ryan long love for
Chloe lebranch at near Comedy Club East
Village and you can follow me on social
media at philanthropygal Tick Tock
Twitter and Instagram thank you
all right pimp ready all right the
winner is with 52 yes on truffles
I can't believe people didn't know it
and it still got it only got 52 percent
you gotta remember if they thought it
was chocolate
whatever just say you love me that's
remix no if we get it under five percent
margin we we should it's a rematch so
funny that's wild you have to do a
follow-up poll did you think we mean
chocolate yes no people are adding me on
the side saying we have no idea what
this is that is so funny because yeah
it's like to me it's like macaroon
macaron it's like those are def
different things really a macaron is a
French cookie a macaroon is a Jewish
cookie macarons are [ __ ] disgusting
and another truffle-like item and
macaroons are delicious I'm not a fan of
either to be honest I don't love coconut
so it has to be very low on the uh
coconut quality for macaroons but I do
like I'm not a fan of either Rook is way
better though anyway we still love you
Christina thank you we still love you
thank you thank you thank you I love you
too I love you too I love you too wow I
know
of taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds man yeah they're coming
to them